Je m'attendais à un combat acharné J'ai
beaucoup fait subir à ma famille Allons-y, comment vous battez-vous
Je ne trouve pas comme ça un
champion des poids lourds légers
Je ne serais pas ici sans ma femme
Maureen
cette citation est consciente de la tragédie que votre
famille a  souffert néanmoins vous avez
choisi de démontrer des
comportements dangereux ou la garde de l'enfant doit
rester avec les services à la famille jusqu'à ce que le
père puisse démontrer les capacités d'
un parent responsable
aucune idée oh pas de brise Billy espère que
mon gymnase je cherche un emploi peut-être que kcj
ne pourrait pas  gérer à nouveau le combat Roseate
obtenir mon enfant
mon chien
mr.  Gotti
vous contrôlez votre destin
vous